[Applause]
it's the moment millions of fans the
world over have waited eight series and
73 episodes for their comic
our enemy doesn't time
since Game of Thrones started in 2011
the question of who will sit on the Iron
Throne has been one of the most talked
about argued over and critiqued outcomes
in TV history
I definitely think that I'd like
they committed to this
I know death he's got many faces over
the last eight seasons the backstabbing
and power struggles have had audiences
enthralled with its nudity violence and
jaw-dropping plot twists proving
unmissable
the Canion aspects of the Game of
Thrones has been appealing to
individuals to talk to an audience which
would never reform themselves as friends
as in genre lovers and and it even
though the series even began I think
pretty much the first thing with a
supernatural element that then receded
and it was all about the strategizing
and the politicking in the deal making
and the deal breaking which has kept
people in since the final series kicked
off six weeks ago it's been dividing
audiences as much as delighting them
with over a million people signing a
petition to have the eighth season
rewritten the thing is it always has
divided fans you know it always has
divided viewers there have been a lots
of viewers that were just like no it's
not for me it's not for me but now I
think there's something with them the
ridiculous like a hundred million people
will watch this final episode so it
clearly is for a lot of people I think a
lot of people are just upset that it's
ending if you play the game of Thrones
you win or die and although this season
has been divisive the fact over 45
million people are expected to watch the
last ever episode is surely testament to
the show's incredible success